Researchers have shown that a swarm of reactive
robots can function as a team
to solve a complicated puzzle--
without reasoning or explicit programming.
They placed a swarm of 20 hockey-puck shaped robots
inside an arena
The swarm’s goal was to enter each booth
in the correct order
The bots sport LED lights,
cameras, and infrared transceivers,
Only robots within close proximity--
within about 20 to 30 cm --
could communicate.
Each unit was programmed with the same
predefined roles:, guardian, runner, tail, or link.
At the start of each trial, all of the bots
are runners and move randomly about the field.
The first runners to enter each of the booths
become guardians, setting up just outside of the
booths to give instructions to other runners.
The guardians receives a signal from the booth.
If it is the first in the sequence the signal is yes.
If not, the guardian is in front of ether 2 or 3.
To navigate from booth to booth the robots form
a chain from the guardian of the first booth.
The last link in the chain is the tail
and searches in a sweeping motion for
a robot to become the next link in the chain.
Once the chain reaches the second guardian,
the process is repeated, creating a chain ending
at the remaining guardian.
The remaining free bots are runners and
use the chain as a pathway,
taking instruction from the guardians
whether or not to enter the booths.
A guardian that is unsure of whether it is in front
of booth 2 or 3 will ask a runner
that has performed exactly one task to enter its booths.
If this runner receives a yes signal from the booth,
the task is the second in the sequence.
Otherwise, it is the third.
Once the guardians have learned the position
of their task in the sequence, they will guide
the runners to complete the tasks
in the correct sequence.
Over 10 trials, the researchers showed that
the swarm was able to accomplish something
very complex through trial and error --
by only reacting to their nearby environment.
The study overturns conventional wisdom
that robots can solve complex tasks in only one
of two ways-- and not both.
1. They could either use deductive reasoning to plan
or 2. They could react in programmed ways
to set situations.
In this conglomeration of bots--both are happening.
The ability to plan emerges from
the interaction of simple reactive bots
And this type of swarm is scalable.
The same programming and sensors
could serve a swarm of 100 or 10,000.
While there’s no immediate applications for this,
researchers working with these bots
are really seeking to expand our understanding
of how swarms of robots cooperate and become
more than the sum of their parts--like bees  or ants.
At the end of the day, the old saying still rings true
there’s no ‘I’ in team…
or in robot for that matter...